in grünstadt in der pfalz sind sie
mächtig stolz auf ihren bahnhof in der
kaiserzeit gebaut steht das schmuckstück
für fast 150 jahre bahngeschichte doch
die bahn von heute schafft es nicht in
grünstadt zwei funktionstüchtige aufzüge
zu betreiben die bleiben immer wieder
stecken oder sind ganz defekt mühsam
müssen kinderwagen rollatoren und gepäck
die treppen hoch und runter getragen
werden seit sechs jahren geht das schon
so
das ist sehr blöd ich muss hier die
treppen runter gehen dann komme ich hier
vorne an ich muss wieder treppen rauf
mit dem schweren kinderwagen ich sag's
grad jetzt auf gut deutschen schweinerei
was sie als abgeht
es macht mich sauer weil also es kann ja
irgendwo nicht sein wenn man darauf
angewiesen ist mit kinderwagen will in
grünstadt ankommt um den aufzug nehmen
muss erlebt häufig dass die edelstahl
kabinen sind außer betrieb wenn sie
zwischendurch doch mal funktionieren
sollten bleiben sie gerne auf halber
strecke stecken 64 personen musste
allein die freiwillige feuerwehr
grünstadt bislang befreien dass die bahn
es nicht schafft zwei aufzüge am laufen
zu halten ärgert die ehrenamtlichen
feuerwehrleute kolossal
wir erwarten also auch von der bahn dass
die aufzüge jetzt mal repariert oder
ausgetauscht werden weil es in einsätze
für uns die sehr viel zeit brauchen und
auf die wir auch gerne verzichten
könnten
das dauerärgernis bahnhofs aufzüge ist
inzwischen auch in grün städte rathaus
angekommen
hier fühlt man sich nicht ernst genommen
das wird immer schlimmer
und wir reden mit der bahn und jetzt ist
die perspektive neue aufzüge
da wurden wir jetzt bereits drei mal
vertröstet erst sollte es im oktober
passieren dann so im dezember passieren
jetzt ist es für 2009 10 avisiert
die deutsche bahn ist mittlerweile um
schadensbegrenzung bemüht schriftlich
heißt es unser ziel ist die anlagen
stets in einem funktionsfähigen zustand
zu halten die unannehmlichkeiten für
unsere kunden bedauern wir sehr
den austausch der aufzugsanlagen werden
wir so schnell wie möglich umsetzen
an eine schnelle lösung glauben viele
grün städter schon lange nicht
mehr ich bin persönlich noch nie mit dem
aufzug gefahren weil er nie funktioniert
barrierefreiheit ist hier nicht das ist
natürlich nicht bei ärgerlich dass das
macht mich auch sauer weil alle die die
auf barrierefreiheit angewiesen sind
die gucken in die röhre nun peilt die
deutsche bahn den mai 2009 10 am dann
soll neue aufzüge in betrieb gehen
bis dahin heißt es in grünstadt
kinderwagen tapfer die treppen hoch und
runter schleppen und im notfall weiter
die freiwillige feuerwehr rufen